musique il me voilà sur le pur d'amener
notre spectacle dans la capitale
mondiale du divertissement
je vous donne trois semaines pour un
show parfaitement huilé jeune qui n'a
pas traité tu vas travailler avec le top
des chorégraphes de reacher city c'est
un peu le mmo il me fit trophy qui se
gardent les pointes tensions et points
de tourny je ne vois pas des points car
j'ai bien réfléchi moi j'ai des doutes
pour ce projet
[Musique]
tu peux pas faire ça je vais essayer
le fantastique elle est incapable de
jouer tiens prends ça méchants petits
monstres d'extraterrestres
alors j'étais bien alors là
vous ne savez absolument pas dans quoi
vous mettez les pieds je vais vous dire
je ne sais pas tu es trou paumé sorte
mais il faut qu'ils aient retourne
pouvons pas laisser cette brute nous
voler nos espoirs et nos rêves du cran
de la foi voilà ce dont vous avez besoin
maintenant
résultat
bonsoir j'ai l'immense plaisir de vous
inviter à une représentation unique
marquant le retour plus légendaires
clair
venez vite mais c'est rare et prenez
place
[Musique]
la peinture de votre ville va bientôt
commencer
[Musique]
il y en aurait quand même pas parmi vous
qui ferez des claquettes
[Musique]